Machine intelligence includes two main
areas.
One is high performance computing,
all the chips you need to do the complex
math required and then artificial
intelligence within artificial
intelligence,
all the breakthroughs are happening in
the area of machine learning and machine
learning includes the ability for
computers to think,
learn and act on their own.
There are a lot of great examples
throughout business government and the
nonprofit world as well.
For example,
in the u s government,
machine learning is completely changing
how census workers visit houses to
collect the census data.
These numerators in the past would just
use their own judgment on what routes to
take and when to visit houses and of
course they often found people not home
and the upcoming 2020 descending hill
census machine learning will actually
give them the best routes and the best
predicted times to find when people are
going to be home.
When people ask me if machine
intelligence will affect them,
I turn the question back around and say,
could you imagine your life or your job
without the Internet?
And most people will say no.
And I say that's how machine
intelligence will become for us.
It's already,
uh,
involved in our personal lives,
whether it's Amazon recommendation
engines or Netflix recommendation,
but it will continue to spread not only
in our personal and entertainment lives,
but also in our day to day work lives as
well.
One example is it departments in
corporations,
many companies spend the majority of
their it budget on it,
operations,
operations and maintenance.
And it's a huge budget line item.
Machine intelligence is now able to
perform most or all of those mundane
routine activities that frees up an
entire skilled workforce to focus on
creativity and innovation beyond the
jobs that they're doing today.
So machine intelligence is not about
completely removing the person from the
equation equation.
It's about machines and humans working
together.
We never recommend that you completely
abandon your judgment as a leader.
Many times machine learning is wrong.
And as leaders we need to recognize that
and know when to ask questions and how
to adapt.
So judgment is still absolutely critical
in this equation.
An interesting example is automated
trucking company,
Otto.
It was formed by Google engineers and
within 10 months bought by Uber for $680
million.
Now,
what would make a company worth $680
million in 10 months?
Well,
auto developed a cab top device sells
for $30,000 and can fully automate any
18 wheeler truck built after 2013
in fact,
they've already made their first
delivery using a self driving truck.
It was 50,000 cans of Budweiser beer
last year.
Right now the truck can't handle every
situation.
It's really great on the highways,
but it has problems in bad weather and
on city streets.
So for now the drivers continue to ride
in the cab,
but when they're on the highway,
the drivers free to conduct whatever
activities they choose.
And I love the story of a driver doing
yoga while going down the highway.
And then the driver takes over in
difficult situations,
there is no question that artificial
intelligence will replace certain types
of tasks.
There are tasks today that machines are
better at than people.
Tasks like organizing,
remembering,
finding patterns.
So those kinds of tasks will be replaced
by machines.
But people are still so much better at
creativity and framing problems and
reasoning.
So what will happen is that machines
will replace the row,
some of the rote tasks that people are
doing today.
And it's up to us then to figure out as
leaders,
what do we do with that talent and how
do we take advantage of the opportunity
that that gives us.
So it's not a matter of machines putting
people out of work across the board.
What goes hand in hand with that are the
new businesses that it will create the
new industries that it might spawn and a
whole new set of demands that aren't,
that don't exist today that um,
people will be,
be able to go into for a second or third
career.
One example of this is the data science
bowl.
Every year we put on the data science
bowl with Kaggle and we choose a really
hard social good problem.
Kaggle puts it out to its community of a
million data scientists around the world
and they saw they work as volunteers to
solve the problem.
Last year the challenge was around heart
health and this year it was around new
ways of predicting lung cancer and of
the top 10 winning teams,
many of them had no background in the
medical field whatsoever.
Prior to this competition,
they were able to learn with the medical
knowledge they needed through tutorials
and because they came at it from
different angles and different
perspectives,
they were able to make breakthroughs in
the lung cancer challenge.
The top 10 algorithms will improve by
10% the accuracy of predicting lung
cancer.
In fact,
one of the winning teams has already
secured venture capital funding to turn
that algorithm into a new business.
So that's an example of a business that
didn't exist previously and is launched
because of machine intelligence.
As a society,
we need to make sure we help folks whose
jobs will be taken over by ai because
there will certainly be tasks that are
no longer that no longer require a
person to do them.
They answer to that dilemma is to
retrain those folks into different
skillsets that can be applied to the new
industries and the new companies and the
new jobs that are created.
So the best policy position that we can
take as a nation is to invest in
retraining those workers.
It doesn't help to deny the problem or
to think that it's way out when it's
already happening today.
We need to be proactive about retraining
that workforce so that we don't have a
class of people left behind.
And by the way,
this doesn't apply only to blue collar
type jobs.
For example,
doctors,
their jobs will be completely disrupted
and change,
will no longer rely on a doctor's
knowledge or experience to diagnose and
treat diseases.
Instead of doctors would become
interpreters of models.
The legal profession will be disrupted
no longer.
While we require people to do research
on precedents and caselaw machines will
be able to do that.
So it affects every walk of life and
every industry,
but we need to invest in the people who
are displaced so that we take full
advantage of that talent to use toward
greater ends.
One thing I'd say about barriers is that
anyone can learn machine intelligence.
Many people feel like this is something
they had to major in in school,
or they have to work at a tech company
to become an expert that's no longer
true.
Many of the leaders that we interviewed
for our book have no background in
machine intelligence whatsoever before
they took on these projects,
and so anyone can and should learn about
machine intelligence.
It will be that much of a game changer.